autre rassemblement avec pour origine
des violences policières présumées
hier à bondy en région parisienne
manifestation d'une centaine de
personnes on soutient gabriel djordjevic
cet adolescent de 14 ans a été arrêté
pour un vol de scooter dans la nuit du
25 au 26 mai une interpellation qui lui
a coûté entre autres une fracture près
de l'oeil gauche et trois dents cassées
parmi les militants réunis hier des élus
locaux et nationaux mais aussi chérif le
grand frère de la victime à ce dernier
est hospitalisé à l'hôpital necker à
paris il doit être opéré aujourd'hui
l'igpn la police des polices est saisie
de l'enquêté
je propose d'écouter nos âmes anwar il
est délégué syndical vigier auteur du
livre la france doit savoir aux éditions
poids c'est la énième affaire de
violences dites policière puisque
naturellement si on parle de violences
policières ces bois s'enlève un peu de
neutralité aux propos donc en attendant
d'avoir la suite on dira que c'est
symptomatique d'une tension permanente
qui gangrène en fait l'entente ce qui
est extrêmement présente dans la vie des
habitants de banlieue puisqu'il ne se
passe pas une journée sans qu'on puisse
entendre parler d'une affaire de
violences entre la police et la
population est donc naturellement il va
falloir retrouver un petit peu
d'apaisement
donc je tiens à porter à votre
connaissance que le colis sera diffusé
un communiqué ce matin au personnel de
l'apb personnels administratifs et
personnel policier ce qui est un
communiqué assez offensif en fait dans
lequel je reconnais ni le racisme n'est
les violences policières aux
institutions ils estiment que l'image de
l'institution est attractif et et il se
positionne en défenseur a juste de la
police contre les attaques dont elle
fait